there he is how are you brother yokas
good man really yeah Brad my pleasure -
pleasure Brad I got water yeah
[Music]
now look I know your wine I'm not gonna
[ __ ] you all not very typical wine
you probably know I know this wine super
well enough I'm a big thing fans one of
my boys he has a place American whiskey
here in the city
yep and I know you like Barolo so yep
that's very nice in the man how'd you
first get in touch with my stuff
um bro it was like ramen I say even
messy yeah I was just [ __ ] going
through yeah you know like [ __ ] man
and you know how big believe everything
happens for a reason when it does yeah
we're trying not a transition but I'm
like you know with your real
entrepreneurial like I met with this bad
company yeah and they're like yeah like
cuz I was like you know it was really
interesting to me I'm gonna meet him one
day like the punch over to Jay's he's
like oh that dude was like selling bags
for us in the locker room he's a real
hustler you know I'm talking about right
like I was about to buy that company I
was like wow yeah I was like this kid is
really in it and so it was weird when I
came across your [ __ ] because it was
like the right time I guess for me you
know that is right teachers yeah that's
like cliche [ __ ] we're talking about
just basically not taking advantage oh
I'm not taking for granted sorry the
platform dude you're [ __ ] on in New
York like it's crazy raisin went wearing
a story [ __ ] and then obviously sorry
[ __ ] and I'm just like I mean look like
like you know you're in New York I mean
look at look at this
yeah I hate the Giants wouldn't I be in
the hashtags this is what I would do if
I were you
Giants right yeah you should check the
Giants hashtag yeah and literally
literally just like a sports car but
like anybody that's gonna be that but
like anything that's here yeah right
like that like like if you just DM that
person be like all right awesome
yeah don't be like holy [ __ ] like like
it will open up [ __ ] all of a sudden
yeah when you do that and you do awesome
as the Giants
Hunter whether they know you were not
next thing you know couple months from
now they're doing are they're doing a
mean with you yeah yeah you know what I
mean
yeah and that's you know but like that
is like to me like Ambrose insane or
your stuff like I have to start you know
ID am [ __ ] companies and they'll send
me like [ __ ] you know what I mean like
it starts off they send me a package of
stuff I have post more about it and they
like it's like it's just like like I
just searching punter right like like
this kid yeah this kid which well the
first hole this might be the this might
actually be the Lions punter no Sam or
on the lines but all right so anyway
nonetheless like just like like just
doing [ __ ] like this yeah like yeah see
I needed I'm real I stuck with the
hashtag ah dude no hashtag well you just
go there you just steam him be like hey
like like keep it going like people were
like yeah there's only 32 of you man
right
how'd you tell me your story so now my
song Melbourne Australia from my dad
it's really become like it's all you
guys are taking over right I know I know
so my dad had a little background in it
he never made a 53 man roster but um he
was with the lines in early nineties
when buried he was Barry Sanders remains
his [ __ ] claim to fame it's just that
ever since I got here man it's been
twits like you know the Australian kid
you know and then I'm putting really
well and then it took [ __ ] like eight
games before I go downhill issues right
on and I go to their camps and then Les
Miles comes to my games it's funny and
again where I placed right time they
were heavily recruiting and kid Nick by
the name of Eric Reed played for the
49ers now came out of this game yep
they were watching him play we were
playing his high school and you booted
the [ __ ] thing but bangin a knock
even he was the part Turner
so he's happened to fair catch he's
getting no highlights upon turning and
Les Miles is sitting there with his wife
like what's his kid stealing from there
you know I had to call my mom at the end
of the I said mama I'm not coming home
they're talking about a scholarship I'm
not gonna
for another five years she's I like
Google a shoe like this shit's legit and
you know man I'm still here you know
from LSU I got and gotten a little
trouble there he did just having too
much fun around the wrong people
yeah of course I mean two years before I
was in Australia you know telemarketing
so a hundred percent so I was having fun
got in some trouble
started off with the Eagles for that
training camp right didn't didn't make
it there you not drafted you signed a
you DFA did yeah
so when with the Eagles just that
training camp was going against the guy
Donnie Jones who was a former LSU punter
we have a great relationship so I was
like [ __ ] weird he had all the better
and moves on me in my head but then that
year what helped me I was being a lefty
so teams would bring me in like the
Patriots did at the Denver Bronco
to prep well yes okay we're playing the
Jets have a left uh-huh so instead of me
going in for workouts like you know
you're just coming into pancho a [ __ ]
party so they can see yeah and and you
know I quickly shifted my mentality
could all like man they're not even
looking at me but then I was like [ __ ]
no one else is plenty in front of these
NFL coaches you something my god it kept
my name in the kind of loop and then I
saw him with the steel is going into
that offseason and then rookie year if
the steel has had a great year they they
boarding another Australian kid and then
I got traded to the Giants week one of
two years ago so we my third year going
into Giants so it's it's been a [ __ ]
crazy ride man but you know I'm very
thankful for it all and like I said I
believe everything happens for a reason
and now here in New York and you signed
a contour like you got locked in right I
got this this past offseason the other
song for a long time so
I mean that's more than you can
everything's job security and I found
them there it's [ __ ] none of it it
doesn't exist so you know I don't care
who you are you hundred percent a
hundred percent you can be gone but it's
just crazy how it worked out because my
roommate in in college was Odell and
your roommates in college was O'Dell
yeah and now we're back on the same team
and it's just like man it's it's just
[ __ ] weird you know you can write the
[ __ ] is what I have a 100% just it's
just something like me being in New York
and it yeah this could be yeah New York
I mean there's nothing like it
I've got a big time year last year huh
thank you man yeah it was a good one it
was you just locked in yeah
what happened you feel comfortable and
that allowed you to focus
yeah have you like changed grips as
anything mechanical going on no I mean
I'm always continued that's the thing I
love what I [ __ ] do that's crazy I
love why it's like to take this ball
right here like I'm looking at this ball
I'm gonna take it and kick it you know
yeah and love it you know and I'll be
here for hours and just try and perfect
it and the game I'm excited to be the
opponent right now in the NFL because
the punting game is changing so the
longest time it's been you [ __ ] hit a
spiral to the return it's changing so
now we're implementing and this again
helps with my Australian football
background because you're kicking all
different kinds of kicks uh-huh
different spins on and now coaches kind
kind of kind of be like wait a minute so
we can follow um books really exactly I
mean we have a changeup on we're wearing
[ __ ] DeSean Jackson's back there you
know he ended up honors career for the I
know where it was the one of the best
one of the best days in my life
I watched that game that was before the
Jets play the Steelers that year that
was the best did you cause a good amount
of fumbles Lasher were you not doing
that yeah no yeah we did we had played
to Sean Jackson two years before that's
was the first time we busted out this
pond they called the boomerang [ __ ]
my car
yeah but I called the boomerang because
it has like a funky spin on it and it
was so crazy for me to see DeSean
Jackson that's what I'm doing it to this
guy looking at it
and struggling he'd [ __ ] back away
from it bounce and they I mean it's a
win you know I mean we play every [ __ ]
returns greater like Tyree kill this
shitty kid from Kansas City yeah [ __ ]
he's not I'm not kicking it to him why
would you you know no reason it doesn't
make it that kids dangerous I think it's
a real exciting time to be a punter
obviously love it a lot more than
anybody else but I love what I do and I
don't feel like I can ever get how many
are there of you now so you really will
you logging me like in Jordan bear from
the Steelers what's so crazy it's both
in you I'm sorry you luck did you lucky
really know each other or second I only
know we played the Jets last year in the
preseason would find again this year too
every year every every right have you
guys hung out yet no I have you sure
yeah absolutely it's like a good idea
they're both in New York yeah there's
probably a whole [ __ ] thing to do
with that absolutely that's just one
plus one equals three for both of my
yeah it's just and for the whole list
you should be you should be a party
Jesus Christ when I was in college I
waivers now there's 33 in college you
know 33 Australian plants in college is
that right [ __ ] insane so like you
guys are just taking over I get hit up
so what you think half the league gonna
be an Australian punter in like three
years
yeah makes sense well taking a ball
everyone grows up here 100% well like
you said the only reason half the people
turn the punting is when they realize
they're out [ __ ] I'm not gonna make it
as a receiver as a quarterback uh-huh so
in Australia my dad taught me everything
about punting
you know I don't know if I put him in
charge of the camp but as far as you
know overwatch you know yeah it could be
like the head coach that gives the other
guys in the tank cause he's there to
watch he's there to watch it but my
whole family's in Australia you all know
only one over here I have a son who's in
Louisiana so you have a son I do four
year old son in louisia really had fun
in college so yeah we got married got
divorced you know went through all right
and I just got the letter yesterday so I
obtained my green card through marriage
and then obviously had to remove the
and I just got the acceptance letter
yesterday song fired oh thank god that's
scary it's just I almost have more
trouble getting in this [ __ ] building
no I mean you know the market in
Australia and here I mean everywhere I
agree with you
I was talking to Ryan Theriot he's a
former baseball player played down daily
I know right and he works being with you
stole a lot of bases yeah yeah he works
bigger with traction school a low
running tournament spoke to me you know
he said we gotta do something for these
kids because there's just nothing did
you know we would get ESPN involved we
get the footage of that and I agree with
you bro that there's a massive massive
market there for it because it's an
overlooked part of the sport you know
unless you're a die-hard for Hanna so
it's another little career I think
anything I can help you with that you've
seen like from afar like what you know
your connections are insane but just
just just you know this I just wanted to
know me everywhere yeah that's a good
starting point yeah just start start
this relationship and you know I'm sure
you know the fact that you've told me to
hit you up if I can percent I think that
listen I talked to Brandon all the time
and like I really think you should have
blocky and we should get together just
do me one favor like take one piece of
ice on me DM tenth everyday like in the
same way that you [ __ ] practice for
three hours ten DMS five to fans
hashtag punch our hashtag Giants yeah be
like yo thing right yeah and five to
just [ __ ] people that you want to get
like yeah right yeah [ __ ] work and
like and be smart like lucky for slick
what the fact that you guys haven't
connected it's just like either what
either you guys are just being too
prideful like who's gonna hit up who or
you just being silly that's just not
smart right right alright keep me
updated absolutely yeah all right yo
pleasure man yeah for sure absolutely
cool man better than bro
[Music]